good afternoon everyone my name is dr.
Miller and the SCP were going to be
looking at today is SCP 621 object class
Euclid special containment procedures
all instances of scp-610 t-one are to be
kept in the site 16 greenhouse and
watered regularly seeds and pollen from
SCP 621 are not to be released into the
wild no instances of scp-610 trade given
as gifts used as props used as bribes or
stored in personnel offices personnel
are advised not to look at a CP 621 for
extended periods of time
[Music]
addendum 621 3 personnel are advised not
to look at a CP 621 through sunglasses
which has recently been shown to
increase SCP 621 s mental effects only
on filtered lab goggles may be worn
around SCP 621 it should be of
additional note that unfiltered lab
goggles lab glasses or other transparent
obstructions will not shield SCP 621 s
effects any instances of scp-610 t one
found in the wild are to be exterminated
immediately any instances of scp-610
public are to be confiscated and whoever
in possession at the time be taken in
for questioning
civilians actively wandering a CP 621 in
the wild are to be detained and the
instances of scp-610 may use physical
force in order to protect SCP 621
cross-pollination of SCP 6 21 species
will require clearance from command
level personnel no cross-pollination x'
may be done for personal reasons
description SCP 6 21 is a series of
highly invasive flowering plants
originally released by the flower shop
that have been in the foundations
possession as of these plants mainly the
plant species Didier's tulips are
naturally bioluminescent powered by
water and other nutrients
these plants glow a variety of colors
though most instances glow purple blue
or green this bioluminescent effect can
be best seen at night or in a dark area
the effect is only active while the
plants are alive SCP 6 21 particularly
its glow seems to have a hypnotizing
effect on humans with numerous requests
by personnel to store them in their
personal offices all of which have been
denied SCP 6 21 has varying effects on
other animals when exposed to these
hummingbirds or cross pollinating
animals all of the animals subjected
have preferred spreading the pollen of
SCP 6 21 as opposed to other flowering
plants and due to its bioluminescence
are capable of doing this at night
increasing its rate of reproduction
however when exposed to herbivores such
as deer or rabbits all of the subjected
animals have actively avoided SCP 621
with a high fertility rate a natural
defense against predators and a
hypnotizing effect on humans SCP 6 21
can be deemed a highly effective
invasive species addendum 621 for upon
further testing SCP 621 s pollen gives
off a strong thought to be pleasant
aroma SCP 621 is completely
hypoallergenic and when personnel with
allergies are exposed to up to 5 grams
of SCP 6 21 s pollen
personnel displayed no allergic
reactions when placed around other
plants SCP 6 21 aggressively absorbs
nutrients that would normally be
absorbed by the other plants potentially
to fuel its bioluminescence as a result
SCP 6 21 quickly drains the soil of
nutrients and requires more water than
all other plants in the site 16
greenhouse before being actively
monitored by the foundation SCP 621 had
invaded multiple farming pastures but
because of its hypnotic qualities
nothing can be done to stop them
in addition sympathizers actively
watered the invading plants during their
incursions
although government agencies such as the
USDA and EPA protect against these sorts
of invasive species said agencies have
actively defended a CP 621 at the
expense of commercial farmers it may be
of note that these farmers have since
accepted the situation citing SCP 621 s
aesthetic superiority to their own crops
and their desire to protect SCP 621 the
foundation stepped in when SCP 621 began
invading national wildlife preserve
threatening several instances of both
endangered plants and animals the EPA
refused to hinder the spread of SCP 621
despite the existential risk to plants
and animals on grounds that it would
have made the national wildlife preserve
more aesthetically pleasing
although Didier's tulips are the most
common type of SCP 621 there also exists
species of SCP 6 21 that include other
types of tulips roses and a few
instances of lettuce as a result of
cross-pollination however no d-class
personnel could bring themselves to eat
SCP 621 worried about possible side
effects when force-fed SCP 621 induces
intense anxiety and paranoia on the
subject but no other side effects
the anxiety dissipates upon digestion
this effect has been seen on multiple
test subjects addendum 621 one in light
of the recent events involving doctors
warning several instances of scp-610
elan site sixteen are allowed to keep at
least one instance of scp-610 Phasis
addendum 621 - in light of dr. public
apology for hoarding several instances
of scp-610 longer allowed to keep any
instances of scp-610 Phasis note to
everyone asking me to ask the
administration to release sav 621 to the
public this is the very reason we're
keeping SCP 621 here i don't care if it
looks cool or if i had a few in my
office for a while i know firsthand that
this thing has some kind of hypnotizing
effect on people and something is
telling me that this plant has possibly
evolved for that very purpose if our
government agencies won't stop these
things we will
I don't know if it's just me but is
anyone else getting a little shop of
horrors feel off this one no just me
anyway I think that about does it for
today thank you all for listening if
indeed you still are and you were all
dismissed
goodbye I would like to give a special
thank you to the reclusive extrovert
geum's sabah chris ball pablo ice 917
kareem al a Schmo e justin day Thomas
Morin
Traver w peg white crew and jayvo check
my archive curator neck tie verbal
court's five six three and the wanderer
thank you all so much for your support I
really appreciate it if you would like a
special thank you at the end of each of
my videos not on some other cool stuff
as well visit patreon.com forward slash
the Volgin thank you
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]